several passengers suffered broken bones
after their plane encountered severe
turbulence video shows people injured on
the floor of the Aeroflot plane
yesterday shortly before the Boeing
triple7 landed in Thailand at least 27
were hurt the airline confirmed the
incident was the result of clear air
turbulence the most difficult type to
detect new research suggests
transatlantic turbulence could become up
to three times worse in the coming
decades
mark Strassman is at a dallas-fort Worth
International Airport with those
concerns mark good morning good morning
for nervous Flyers nothing about this
research is reassuring clear air
turbulence strikes without warning and
because of climate change
could get worse the sudden drop came
without warning anyone not strapped down
was shot toward the ceiling then slammed
against the aircraft floor video of the
aftermath shows the plane scattered with
debris severe turbulence can be
terrifying for unsuspecting passengers
as it was in this Boeing triple7
bond for Jakarta last year unlike
conventional turbulence that occurs when
planes fly near weather systems clear
air turbulence happens without the
presence of clouds making it nearly
impossible for pilots to detect until
it's too late dr. Paul Williams is an
atmospheric scientist at the University
of Reading in England we've calculated
that the amount of severe turbulence
which is strong enough to hospitalize
people could double or even as much as
treble by the end of this century on
transatlantic flight routes because of
climate change according to researchers
rising carbon dioxide levels could
destabilize the fast-moving air currents
of the transatlantic jet stream an area
that currently sees up to 3000 flights a
day they predict a 149 percent spike in
severe air turbulence along with longer
travel times increased delays and
inevitably higher ticket prices it's
very distressing for pilots precisely
because they have no indication or very
little indication that that turbulence
is sitting out there and that the plane
is just about to hit it this is about
five years old
space engineer Pat Anderson took us
inside a flight simulator to give us the
pilots perspective this is light
turbulence here very manageable very
manageable the autopilot could fly the
airplane at this point okay moderate
turbulence so about 50% how much more
significant than light turbulence
there's the potential for things to go
sideways and slide off your table it's
probably a little uncomfortable at this
point severe turbulence how challenging
for the pilot severe turbulence is by
definition the pilot is challenged in
trying to fly the airplane so now the
pilot may be doing things to mitigate
that turbulence one thing would be to
get out of it with extreme turbulence
like this what's going on I think when
you get to the point of saying extreme
you're worried about being in a
situation where the airplane is in
jeopardy severe turbulence is a true
test of a pilot and his skill and his
ability to adapt it is so in the pilot
that goes GoPro severe turbulence just
cost us our GoPro modern airliners are
designed to withstand all kinds of
turbulence but experts warn that even
airplanes have a breaking point assuming
this this again the thesis is right how
nervous will air carriers be about the
integrity of their planes
well the integrity of the airplanes is
something that's going to have to be
checked as this happens airplanes don't
have infinite lights they have some
limit and if we see more turbulence
that's going to be drawn in closer
for Americans who fly turbulence poses
the greatest safety risk
last year the FAA investigated 44
injuries connected to turbulence that
was up more than double from the year
before Nora Marc thanks
I mean I'd fly multiple times a week and
I would say I've noticed it I've noticed
the increase in turbulence one of my
nightmares right there flying from LA to
DC the other day we had what the pilot
described as moderate turbulence but it
was really terrifying in the flight
attendant came and said you know can I
get you anything I said yes a diaper
yeah I was really that afraid no I
really did say I mean people started
laughing it was nervous laughter because
we were all afraid I know that's why you
left your hanging bag back as soon as
you wanted to get off my plane on fire
yeah it was very very afraid and the
flight attendant said it's gonna get
worse
this is it and you never really know how
bad it that's right charlie scary